يدير أندريه إيرماك مكتب زيلينسكي
وهو ينضم إلي الآن من كييف، أهلًا بك
مرحبًا بك مرة أخرى في برنامجنا،
لا أعرف من أين أبدأ، أعتقد
أن البدء بسؤالك هل
تمكنت أنت وفريقك من فهم ما
حدث في  روسيا وعلى وجه التحديد هل
فكرت كيف يمكن أن
تفيدك أو العكس
أولاً وقبل كل شيء مرحبًا أه كما
ترى أود أن أقول إن
500 يوم تقريبًا
من النضال البطولي لأوكرانيا
دمرت أسطورة اختفاء
الجيش الروسي
وأعتقد ذلك  الأحداث وكل
هذه الأشياء في الأيام الأخيرة تم
تدميرها أخيرًا أسطورة
أن كل شيء في روسيا
أه تحت السيطرة
يمكننا رؤية هذه السيطرة
وبالطبع أعتقد أنه أه
دليل آخر على أن الذي يهدف إلى
إحياء  لقد فشل الاتحاد السوفييتي أخيرًا،
وأعتقد أن
هذه إشارة قوية جدًا
إلى أن
الحرب في أوكرانيا
هذا
الغزو الهمجي غير القانوني الرهيب الذي بدأ
في 24 فبراير من العام الماضي
والحرب كما تعلمون بدأت منذ سنوات عديدة
في عام 2014. بالطبع
كل ما حدث في  روسيا
الأيام الأخيرة هي النتائج هي نتائج
هذه الحرب وهذه هي نتائج
كيف قلت عمليا 500 يوم من
تفكك الأمم الأوكرانية
وأه كما تعلم أعتقد أنه
بعد هذه الأحداث أصبح المزيد من الناس في
العالم أكثر ثقة بشأن الأوكرانيين  النصر
حسنًا، دعني أطرح عليك سؤالين
للمتابعة، الأول هو الرد على ما قد
يكون تفكيرًا بالتمني من
معسكرك وربما العديد من المعسكرات الأخرى التي قمت
بالتغريد بها خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع بينما كان كل هذا
يدور حول الحرب الأهلية الروسية كانت
النتيجة المعقولة الوحيدة  بالنسبة لغزو بوتين
غير القانوني لأوكرانيا،
يُظهر لنا التاريخ أن جميع الطغاة ينهارون في نهاية المطاف
تحت وطأة
تناقضاتهم حتى غطرستهم، لذا
حسنًا، يظل بوتين في السلطة، لقد
قدم للتو بعض الأدلة على حقيقة
أنه كما تعلم يحدق في بريغوسيان
ولكن هل تعتقد أن هذا هو  أول ما
تعرفه هو وجود ثغرة خطيرة في درعه
أم أنه سيتضاعف لأنه
خرج إلى القمة، كما
تعلم أنهم
بدأوا في النزول
وبدأوا كما نعتقد نحن الأوكرانيون أنهم
بدأوا في 24 فبراير من العام الماضي
ولكن في هذه الأيام الأخيرة  أكثر أكدوا
أنهم لا يسيطرون على الوضع
أه إنهم لا يعيشون في الواقع
وبالطبع لا يمكنهم أه
اتخاذ بعض
القرارات الحقيقية وأه
أعتقد
بأي شكل من الأشكال
أننا جميعًا في العالم
نشاهد هذا العرض أه
وبالطبع لكن  بأي شكل من الأشكال أعتقد أنه
سيكون له
تأثير تاريخي وخطير للغاية على كل ما
سيكون في المستقبل
وبالطبع أنا متأكد من أن الكثير من
الناس أه في العالم وخاصة في
العديد من زعماء العالم
سيغيرون رأيهم وسيغيرون رأيهم
ثق
بكل ما قال وسيقول أه
بوتين في المستقبل